democrats and teachers unions have made
an utter mess of your children's
education nearly 1.3 million students
have left public schools since the start
of the pandemic many students are so far
behind it could take them two years to
catch up academically and right before
the start of the new year there is now a
nationwide teacher shortage but teachers
unions and liberal lawmakers who push
these lockdown policies and are hope are
hoping people will forget all about it
but first
they must reopen
safely
we know that kids need in-person
learning and that remote instruction is
no substitute for it
but it has to be safe bottom line
learning is non-negotiable but neither
is safety we estimate at this moment at
least over 90 percent of our students
you can argue it's
closer to 95 97
of our students are likely to start the
school year with distance learning and
as we get closer to the midterms
democrats are trying to win back parents
by talking about everything but
education so greg
don't you think that more people would
leave the public school system if they
could but they're trapped it's one of
the upsides of the pandemic is people
actually saw what the teachers were
doing to their kids this is another
example of this weird flip going on used
to be the democrats rallying cry was
what about the children that's all you
heard it became kind of a point of
mockery what about the children children
are the future now it's what about the
teachers unions what about the drag
performers they should be allowed to
perform in classrooms what about the
rights of the non-binary instructor to
explain their gender preferences to a
toddler
the republican party is the de facto
party for the parents
what if i mean what would you rather
align with if you had kids i don't have
them so i'm just speaking for the
parents here but would you rather have a
be part of a party that wants your kids
taught or shut down lockdown or
targeting parents as domestic terrorists
or that actually support your parents
it's only one party that's really doing
it and it's the republicans basically
parents are free money on the table and
the republicans should get up there and
grab it and talk about the numbers of
these kids not being in school the
damages to their psyche the obsession
with sexuality the desire for surgery to
correct toddler behavior is it isn't
biden actually paying for now like uh
breast implants for men i mean this is
the the democrats in a way
have turned children into experimental
subjects
you know through biology through gender
through education so republicans now
have to be the rescue squad they have to
be the parents party i think it's kind
of happening but they're usually really
slow on these things that's why i have
to kick him in the pants so kennedy um
there's been a number of republican
governors who've decided that actually
we can't afford for people to take their
kids out of public school because
they're still paying property taxes for
the public school system so we're going
to allow them to take some of that money
and actually put it towards the
education of their choice which has
opened up a number of opportunities for
parents in school choice and that's what
the school choice movement is all about
actually having the choice it's one
thing to say we'll send your kids
private most families can't afford
thirty thousand dollars a year per
student but if it were something like
six or seven thousand a year and that's
what you're already paying in taxes for
your kids then places like arizona are
signing you know the governors are
signing legislation uh that goes through
the state legislature that allows
parents to make those choices if you
want your kids to as greg said uh have
lectures about
gender preference and everything then
you can send your kids to school like
that that's fine if that is what you
want go do a bang-up job if you actually
want your kids to be in an environment
in school in person where they're
learning math and science
and reading then maybe you should be
able to have that choice and i hope
there are more lawmakers and more states
that allow parents to do that because
teachers unions overplayed their hand
there are two things parents will not
forget americans not just parents the
withdrawal of afghanistan and what
public schools have done to kids in this
country that was exposed during the
pandemic they will not forget that as
much as they try with the smoke and
mirrors to make it all magically go away
so jesse while people like randy
weingarten were up there talking about
how things had to be safe and they
wanted to reopen but had to take care of
themselves first rather than thinking
about the long-term effects of keeping
children out of schools they were
basically holding the taxpayers hostage
for more money that has been now spent
inappropriately and we know that they
basically exclusively donate to
democrats so it's a money laundering
operation the teachers unions say hey
guys we can't teach unless the
classrooms are clean so send us all this
cash and then they take the cash they
don't open up the classrooms and then
they send the cash back in terms of
donations and then all the test scores
go down and the teachers unions say the
same thing and they say see this is why
we need more money so we can hire more
teachers that can donate more to you
guys as a political party and then the
there's a discrepancy between the white
scores and the black scores and they say
see this is why we need crt
because it's a racist system and then
all the students come back from the
lockdowns all psychologically damaged
from the lockdowns and they say see this
is why we need to push this gender
propaganda on these kids and groom them
and then all the parents say wait a
second i don't like this at all and the
teachers unions say butt out this is our
child and then have the bible
administration slap like terrorist tags
on them i don't think the republicans
are going to do anything about this it
kind of reminds you of that mortgage
meltdown in 2008 when everyone was like
put these guys in jail from wall street
was a single wall street banker that
cooked up this paper prosecuted nobody
same with the fouchy thing he's not
being criminally investigated
january 6 did not damage the country as
much as these lockdowns but we have
hearing after hearing after hearing on
january 6 and no hearing on the lockdown
if you are a public policy person and
you're pushing public policy that's
killing people that's destroying
people's civil rights and hurting a
generations of kids brains you should be
able to be prosecuted criminally so
jessica the world bank estimates that
because of this lack of learning and the
lockdowns
they've lost 17 trillion dollars of
earning potential for the generation
that was kept out of school
so given the damage the teachers union
has done to itself
what is the democrat solution to making
up for lost time and also trying to get
kids back to public school given the
environment
well i think that democrats need to talk
specifically about the american rescue
act dollars that went to these schools
that haven't been spent and to be very
clear that they want to see it go into
summer school resources after school
tutoring mental health services
everything to try as best we can to
protect the kids that are still in the
system and then a national campaign to
get those 1.3 million kids that are in
school anymore um back there if they can
and to make a a coaching argument it's
homeschooling they're still in school no
no back to the public school system
right yeah some kids though are not in
school anywhere we did lose kids that
just stopped
right just disappeared and there's no
accounting for them especially in major
metropoles so i think democrats need to
talk about this if you look at what
happened in virginia glenn young is the
governor there because the education
issue and he ran i i want to bifurcate
what he talked about he talked about
this problem he didn't talk about crt or
drag queen story hour because he was
like listen there are moderates and on
both the democratic and republican side
and independents who are not going to be
persuaded by that they're not buying
this argument but they do care that
their kids were masked or they do care
that their kids were at home and phil
murphy if you read there was a series of
pieces interviewing democratic voters
about what was going on in new jersey
and this was the only issue where they
were persuadable on because they said i
support the democratic agenda top to
bottom except for the fact that this
happened to my kids and there's nothing
more personal than what's going on with
your children that's true hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now